This was a scene in Ishinomaki on that fateful day.
The coastal city was one of the hardest hit,...
...having lost more than 3,000 residents,...
...84 of them were lost at this one school.
Noriki lost his twelve-year-old daughter here in the 2011 tsunami.
This behind me is what remains of her Okawa Elementary School where she attended.
The water then came up to where that white sign is up on that hill...
...and if the 84 of them had just evacuated above that white sign,...
...then their lives could have been saved.
Instead, the teachers led the students this way, the wrong direction,...
...because this is a dead end and that's where the waves crashed over them.
Noriki wants the world to know what happened here...
...and says the Olympics torch relay was the perfect opportunity.
He applied and was selected as one of the torchbearers...
...who reflect the Olympic spirit.